[Music]
when it comes to football training the
traditional approaches we do all of our
training on the graph as we've become
more experienced and more knowledgeable
over the years a lot of footballers will
do their training also in the gym can
you explain a little bit about just what
type of work they do in the gym and most
of the goal of the function of all of
our strength training in the gym so our
main reason is to try and increase
athletic performance to be stronger to
be more powerful to be quicker to be
better at Jule's to be better at
changing direction and these are the
things that the manager and the coaching
staff will look for on a Saturday in
terms of trying to get the best outcome
for the team
nutrition is really important between
finishing the training session and then
start in a subsequent session you know
we want the players to take in quality
protein to recover from the training
that they've just done and then also
provide an adaptation for the training
that they're going to do the short
turnaround one we've got players going
from pitch to gym on a sort of single
day of training here at Carrington can
be a real challenge the guys like to use
the way 20 gels which are nice and quick
and easy or some of them might prefer
something solid so they might have one
of the protein bars we have the whole
range of options available or a lot of
our players we don't want them to be big
bulky but we want them to be strong and
powerful so we'll put a lot of effort
into profiling the players identifying
their strengths and weaknesses and then
providing them bespoke programs which
you can transfer onto the door in the
gym and when we do a strength session
we'll use the science in sport Reagle
what we're looking to do is provide
nutritional support around all the
sessions to try and hopefully improve
the training adaptation that were giving
them in the gym and the stimulus of that
and the recovery from the session
they've just done
[Music]